all right like to welcome you to
tonight's opening class
we're going to cover the two nights
defense for black an interesting
variation within the two nights is
called the fried liver attack this is
the initial moves after three moves so
I'll go through them from the start
white enters upon the King four or efore
black plays e5 you know when the two
King pawn comes out that's called the
double King pawn at this stage this is
the recommended opening that new chess
players should learn first and the
reason is that the attacks and defenses
the attacks by white defenses are
straightforward and easier to understand
some of the other openings like the pawn
the Queen four or d4 and the English
they have a lot of maneuvering and it's
all positional sort of chest without all
these direct attacks and defenses so
when you start out you should
concentrate on these openings first so
anyway the best move for white is
considered well first you bring out the
center pawn and that marks off the
territory of each side white gets the
first four rows Black's territory are
the top four rows and as you can see the
pawns block each other so black blocks
the white pawn it can't move forward and
in a way that black pawn move
neutralizes White's first pawn move but
the pawn moves let the bishop come out
in the Queen come out on the white
diagonals and they hold back the enemy
pawns for example black can't play pawn
to Queen for while he could but white
can just
it black can take it back with the Queen
but they know that when you trade pawns
that opens up squares for your other
pieces but you don't make a lot of pawn
moves in the opening the main principle
is to bring out the knights and bishops
first and after you do that you want a
castle and then you want to maybe bring
up another pawn in the center and then
bring your rooks to the middle of the
board
that's called rapid development now the
in rapid development you don't want to
move the same piece twice in the opening
for example if you move the well the
next move for white is this Knight to f3
you know chess notation right yes all
right so that's the best move because it
attacks the black pawn which is
undefended and black then normally
defends with the knight and right off
the bat I move to white is attacking and
black is defending White has a time
advantage the advantage of making the
first move that's in chess that's called
a time advantage every move is an
element of time and actually the their
half moves when white plays d4 that's
half move and when black plays e5 that's
the half move together they make a move
pair and you write that on the score
sheet because it's always white and
black so anyway what we've done is two
moves or four half moves again black is
defending white is attacking one because
because white has the first move
advantage he gets to be the attacker in
the beginning of the game that's also
called the initiative
meaning the initiator of the action
black is defending and responding it's
an advantage in chest to be have the
initiative you know in football the team
that wins is the team that can score the
goal
so the whoever has the football they
have the initiative in football they're
on the attack
that's what chess is that it's called
the initiative now one of the standard
moves for move three white brings his
Bishop to c4 and see how it dominates
that white diagonal toward the f7 pawn
so it's attacking the f7 pawn it's
defended by the King hi we just started
we're going to go over the two Knights
defense for black at this stage it looks
like it might be the Italian game and it
would be if black plate is black Bishop
to c5 but we're going to go over the two
knights where black plays Knight to f6
and does a counter attack we are going
to do the Knight to g5 and we're going
to look at the fried liver attack oh by
the way you guys should grab one of
those handouts it covers everything
we're going to go over tonight and you
can read it read about it at your
leisure at home and I put a biography of
the chess players behind the game so you
might read about the Masters okay so now
you may not be he's just started so you
may not be rewarded this setup is
typically leads to what's called the
Italian game and if black were to bring
is Bishop to c5 next to the white Bishop
it would be the Italian opening in
Italian is called the gyoko piano how
would you say that
go show piano and it's translated in
English as the quiet game
they've been playing this opening since
the 1400 was one of the first openings
they were when chests came over from
India and Persia they were first he came
to Italy with the trade routes and
that's what the Italians were playing
and the Grandmaster still play this
today anyway the Italian game if if
played correctly any of the major
openings if both sides play correctly it
should result in a drawn game White has
the first move advantage that litt lasts
anywhere from 15 to 25 moves
depending on the opening some openings
the advantage dissipates faster and some
openings it's last longer so White's
goal is to keep the initiative going as
long as possible and take advantage of
any little mistakes black might make and
increase his advantage and if it gets a
big enough advantage he can win a pawn
or a piece and then that leads to a one
game all right so the two Knights the
knight Black Knight comes out and
counter-attacks on that undefended white
pawn on e5 e for right now there are a
lot of different ways to start from here
for white white could play d3 for
example white can play d4 but we're
gonna go over the knight up which starts
and it violates an opening rule which is
what opening rules yeah see how the
knight move twice and we're only I move
four but it has a strong threat the
knight and Bishop attacked the f7 pawn
only defended by the King so if white
add another move he'd win by Knight
takes pawn fork attack
the Queen in work so their different
ways black can play against that wait so
what black usually does at this point he
blocks the bishop diagonal with pawn up
so you can see that stops the knight
takes f7 threat at least temporarily and
white this pawn takes pawn attacking the
knight on c6 and here's where we diverge
again into different black defenses the
one we're going to go through tonight is
Knight takes pawn that allows white to
sacrifice the knight on f7 and get a
strong attack he gets a pawn and he can
force the black King up to the middle of
the board on the e6 square which you'll
see in a minute my young chess students
love the fried liver attack one of my
students who's like 12 years old he says
he always tries to play the fried liver
attack and I point out to them that you
only get to play the fried liver attack
if Black is crazy and plays Knight takes
pawn that gives white a very strong
attack the fried liver attack and
there's good alternative moves that are
safe for black but in my opinion one of
the best moves instead of the King
Knight taking the pawn you move the
Knight to a5 and attack the bishop you
drive the bishop off the line of the
pawn because the bishop has to move it
involves the pawn sacrifice the bishop
goes up check you move the the c7 pawn
up one squared and attack the bishop
that lets white do pawn takes pawn and
then he's a pawn up you take back with
the pawn
he normally retreats the Bishop to e2 in
front of a king and black gets to drive
the white pieces back and gets
compensation for the pawn it's
considered to lead to an even position
it it's a good safe and aggressive way
to play for black so there's no need for
black to go into the fried liver attack
but for variety the fried liver tech
it's quite complicated and is fun it's
particularly fun in speech s on the
internet or here at the Chess Club but
it's not recommended for tournament play
and look over here you can see that
these grandmasters high rated
grandmasters they're playing the world
championship blitz tournament in Doha in
2016 well guess when I have a database
of Grandmaster games it's updated
through 2017 every year it updates and I
looked up the fried liver attack to see
how many grandmasters actually played
the game guess how many Grandmaster
games show that anybody won this one and
it was only a speed chess game so you
can see that that's why I say the fried
liver attack is the interesting sideline
so we'll jump into this game so this is
the move that lets White initiate the
attack and a white takes the pawn of
course the King has to take now the
Queen comes up with a double attack
checking the king and attacking the
knight the Knights only defended once
it's attacked twice so the king has to
go up one Square to protect the knight
or he loses the knight and white would
get his piece back plus the pawn
the black king would have moved in can't
castle so black would be lost so he's
trying to hold on to the peace at this
point white only has one pawn he needs
two more pawns theory wise to be even
but he has a strong attack that black
King blocks the bishop on c8 the black
King gets in the way of his pieces and
white gets good attack
so here's White's next move
he immediately brings his Knight out and
of course now he has three pieces
attacking the knight and he can't
because the King blocks to the bishop he
can't defend it with the bishop the only
way there's only who in the audience
there's two ways he two moves he can
make to defend the knight what are they
you must know this what are they the
same night to be for the sea Knight goes
either up to b4 or back to e7 now here's
the harder question which of those two
moves is better for black and why what
just use your general chest knowledge
and it doesn't matter if you're right or
not just make a guess that is actually
the best move and it's it's a slight
difference but that's better and there
if you put the knight back to eat the
the problem with bringing the knight to
be for at a certain point the knight
might be exposed to a pawn attack a3 but
you do have that threat of Knight takes
pawn check winning the rook and then
you'd have lots of material
and the the other benefit but there's a
drawback to Knight to d7 and the Queen
but mainly the bishop so that's why the
knight said before is better because the
bishop can come out and help defend
either the e pawn if it goes to D sick I
can't go to d6 because they'd give up
the knight but it can go to e7 and guard
some squares toward the black King now
in this game why black who is Simon egg
dis thing I looked up his biography
because they read a note about him he's
an interesting Grandmaster he's from
Norway who's the most famous chess
player from Norway world champion this
guy was a coach to Magnus Carlsen when
Magnus was coming up and becoming really
good he's no longer as coach but he
brought Magnus a long way toward
becoming a great Grandmaster does it
okay so this guy is very interesting and
he's playing I I think a Russian I'm not
sure though he might be Ukrainian or
some other nationality but it's in the
biography at the back anyway they're
both very good players black chooses
what we just said was the less desirable
move Knight to e7
so what jump into that we'll come back
and I can show you the alternate notice
the chess notation over there where the
moves are see the + / - do you know how
to read those chess notation symbols
well + / - means a big advantage not a
winning advantage a big advantage for
white now if you invert the symbol so
it's minus over plus it's the big
advantage for black now look a big
advantage means you you're starting to
approach a pop the value of a pawn which
is one point now see the little number
in parentheses behind the boob that's
what the chess engine I use a chess
computer engine to evaluate the moves
and it gives us the point score based
that one is one pawn so one point three
means one and a third pawns it's close
to a winning advantage now winning
advantage is for white is a plus on a
straight line with a minus sign to the
right of it and a winning position for
black would be a minus sign and then a
plus you see the black being the second
then the symbol on the right white being
the symbol on the left now they also
have a smaller advantage a slight
advantage that's a plus Oh
were an equal sign that's worth about a
third of upon point three point three
five and a completely equal position and
that is anything under point three of a
pond so 0.20 would be equal is an equal
sign so those are the major things you
would need to know when you see these
things in a computer okay let's see what
white does so white has almost a winning
advantage here now so there's no night
take see two white chooses to Castle
it's a good move
there's an equally good move what would
be another good move for white in this
position who in the audience sees
another good attacking move for white
that king is on the e-file right and
after white castles and the route goes
to the e-file it would be Czech except
there's a pawn or piece blocking the
black King right well you could try to
attack that pawn on e5 to eliminate it
and that would expose the black king so
that's the other good move what's the
other good move then that's right and he
can hardly do pawn takes pawn he can't
do pawn takes pawn you can do Queen the
e4 check driving the King away from the
knight then you would win the knight
with Knight takes Knight so the computer
says that if you do anyway it says d4 is
a good move and a d4 is move nine and
ten moves later the computer says white
still has a big advantage 1.43 a little
bit better but anyway castles is also
good so we'll stick with that obviously
that knight on d5 needs more protection
doesn't it it's not moving it's pin how
could we protect the knight
yeah so c6 in both lines whether that
that Knight goes back to e7 or before
they play c6 so that's that's what
happens c6 now you're going to see a
transposition white chose to castle
first now he hits the five pawn with d4
like I told you and it's not an exact
transposition had white play d4 first
black might have played a different move
or there might be a slightly different
move order or it could transpose
anyway black wants to get his King out
of the center because he's really
exposed there's going to be work to e1
threatening work takes pawn check and
pawn takes pawn
he gets Rick t1 check right away and
there's the Bishop to f4 check if he
goes to d6 so black chooses to move his
King back that unblocks the bishop on
the white squares it can come up and the
king is going to try to hide on c7
behind his pawn on c6 White has a good
attacking move he develops his bishop
pinning the knight to the queen and now
the two rooks are connected so they can
come to the Sun or files and join in on
the King attack so we're at move 11
remember this is a speech s game
probably five minutes it could be
something else the grandmasters didn't
have a lot of time and I don't think
they I know that black didn't know the
opening because at this moment on move
11 black makes a losing blunder so
obviously he didn't know the details of
the opening it was probably just playing
it for fun okay so he plays the losing
move Bishop to e6 now look at the
notation see the two question marks and
know this notation one question mark is
a bad move
that might be a your valuation say you
were even an equal game and you make a
bad move you might drop a third of a
pawn so you if you're black white might
have a point three five advantage but a
double question mark that's a change
from equal to Lou
that's called a blunder so this is a
blunder and I got a little note look how
it changed the valuation for white jumps
up to 2.2 to see the parentheses a
grandmaster can usually win with an
advantage of one pawn or more so 2.22 is
two and a fifth pawns most grandmasters
will win unless they run out of time and
make a blunder in turn and let their
opponent back into the game okay we'll
go through this because it'll wrap-up
hurt and then we'll double back and show
you what he should have played okay the
problem with that move it doesn't it
turns out that the bishop on e6 remember
the King was on e6 and we said the rook
would come over and attack the e-file
what turns out that putting the bishop
on e6 the bishop becomes a target of the
rook and the King's not safe on that
black square after that pawn goes away
there's a bishop to f4 check and there's
a Knight to e4 check on the King see
those so the black King's not safe
either so white plays rook over
threatening rook takes pawn and then the
rook is right on the bishop and the
other work he can double up and threaten
earth takes bishop check
black tries pawn takes pawn now there's
a couple ways to win and I'm going to
show you the alternative because it's
short white plays Knight here check
which should win but there might even be
an easier win why could have played
Queen to g3 check on that black diagonal
that that drives the King back to the
white square and now watch this you
sacrifice the rook King takes so we got
the King back in the middle now we take
the knight remember his other Knight
isn't really defending d5 because they
can't move the Queen would be lost
pawn takes now we have our Rick over
check now the rook and Bishop are on the
knight on e7
the King moves then we have Queen to the
white diagonal to keep the King from
getting hiding on c8
working the little king go the king can
go here if the King goes here
the bishop drops here and then where
does the King go up here but notice the
rook can come and attack the King on
this were a care check then he has to
cover the King has to come up here and
he's almost checkmated well yeah we got
Bishop here check and if King takes
bishop we got Queen here checkmate
he can't move the King the best the
computer come can come up with us start
to giving pieces back he plays the
knight up notice the bishops on the
Queen and we get the night with check
King to c7 we well this is simple so
here we have a rook after a rook takes
Bishop we still have a bishop so that
offsets we have a queen for a rook an
easy one game so you can see that right
here white missed an easy win with Queen
to g3 and I guess he probably missed
this rook sacrifice okay but anyway he
plays Knight here and this should win
too if he follows up where does the King
go now who in the audience of what would
be the right move now there's only one
yes to go back does he go to d7 or c7 if
he goes to d7 we get a night fork knight
to c5 check attacking the king and
Bishop and the rooks on the bishop we
win the bishop with the night and we
attacked the Queen and we have a winning
attack so the only move is to try here
now white plays Queen to g3 check he
can't go to d7 and C eights not very
good either because we have Knight to c5
attacking the bishop so he tries the
King to b6 who sees a a strong move for
a tacky move for white here
hello
how can we check the black king yeah
Queen to b3 that's a very strong move it
forces the King back to c7 and white
doesn't see the winning move it's quite
simple
yeah what's the threat and taking the
bishop on e6 so let's look at it
Knight to c5 he has to retreat the
bishop to c8 to protect the b7 pawn now
what's the winning move this is real
tricky move that's why that's why I
white missed this very tricky move for
white I'll just show it to you I
wouldn't think of it he drops his rook
in the bishop can't take it cuz Knight
takes wood Fork
the king and queen now but believe it or
not that Rick is headed for this square
the bishop can check well the Queen can
check here and the bishop King the work
can come here and the King has no good
squares to go to but I'll show you so
let's say black DRI is d3 now the night
is Gard we want to check here but the
Knights guarding that so we get rid of
the knight
and if politics tonight we get our
Bishop check a black ties Queen takes
Knight that breaks the pin on the Black
Knight but it's too late
Bishop here check where does the King go
and now what do we do
yeah supported by the bishop and we pick
up the Queen for a rook and we win the
game
very nice win right here all white had
to do was Knight here and because of
Queen takes pawn jacket the only move is
Bishop back and dropping the work in and
he gets that rook on e6 and actually
forced the king and queen which is
interesting okay however white agreement
it's only a five-minute game so he
didn't have a lot of time to figure it
out so he repeats moves in when you're
running out of time you often repeat
checks because you make a move and you
can think while your opponent's making
his move okay he goes back now white
should just repeat and then do the rook
to the knight to c5 move again but he
doesn't see that now he plays another
move which should win Knight to d6
what's white white has a threat what's
White's threat
be six Rick takes the bishop on e6 well
once he gets that then he would have
Knight to f7 for king or a queen and
rook okay
this should win look at the valuation
white is the head 3.0 four pawns three
pawns that's the equivalent of a piece
of head it should be an easy win black
plays Queen to d7 it protects the bishop
and now white makes a bad move remember
white was up three pawns 3.04 and he
doesn't see the winning move he plays a
four it's not a bad move and threatens
pawn up check with a strong attack but
notice how the point valuation drops to
one point one nine from three so went
from three pawns up to one Pope to just
barely a win all right so what he should
have done once again he should have
brought the Queen over here check King
back here notice now he can take that
pawn now the King gets the knight but we
pick up the rook okay so we have two
bishops that takes care of blacks two
bishops we have a rook black has rook we
have another rook so he has two knights
versus of rook but his King position is
rook to not develop he can't move the
bishop on f8 and he's got five pawns
White has six pawns materials even but
blacks position is so hopelessly bad
he's lost I didn't put the point
valuation but it's a big plus
for white in fact the obvious threat if
it was White's move he would go here
check if the Queen blocks the check we
would have work takes Bishop check draw
no I take that back
the knight protects well before we do
the Queen check I guess we'd have to
take one some of the Knights off but
anyway Black has the wind but after a
four it's not so clear well they have a
few more moves black plays a five a good
move it gives his King an escape square
and it blocks the pawn they keep it from
going to a five check white place is
queen up protecting the knight black
plays is night over opening is Bishop on
the knight and attacking the Queen only
one move for white what is it has to
move the Queen he doesn't want to lose
the night exactly that's the right move
because you you get the Queen out of the
way you win a pawn now he attacks you
now he's still on your knight what's
your move now it looks like he's going
to get the night you just dropped back
to d3 he does get the knight but you
bring your other rook over you threaten
to get the piece back with Bishop takes
Knight he can't protect the knight with
the rook over because the bishop on g5
guards the d8 square so he has to try to
drive the bishop back now we have a nice
move rook takes
the bishop was protecting the night
Queen takes Bishop takes Knight on the
Queen so we got two pieces for a rook
now notice that if black could somehow
survived the attack he's a whole rook up
but White has a basically a mating
attack black makes his second blunder of
the game he plays Queen to d6 what's the
winning move
any guesses from the audience
yeah queen-to-be five will work he
actually played Queen to b3 but it goes
to the same thing you get the pawn on b7
and not only get the pawn that's a
checkmate
so obviously black must have been out of
time to make that bad second blunder but
he's lost anyway he has to guard this he
has to guard this pawn cuz this check is
gonna threaten to take the pawn rook
here won't cut it
because Queen here check King here the
Queen takes pawn well then he could drop
the Queen here no well we're on the
Queen he has to move the Queen and he
has to protect this pawn okay so the
only way to do that is to go here but
then notice this Knight is attacked and
the Queen was protecting the night and
had to move to protect against the
checkmate so it left the night hanging
okay so now we have black is a rook for
a bishop but again White has the killer
attack King back you drop back the
bishop so you're attacking rook take
work on the Queen the Queen has to move
tries to trade Queens does trade Queens
but then we can put our Bishop safely
and the King comes up and we're going to
take the computers word for it see the
valuation 0.93 a
big plus almost upon up White has
winning chances put it that way there's
not a sure win but winning chances so
black could have held on longer head he
played the right move but black
blundered in time trouble and white got
a checkmate okay now let's go back a
little bit because there's some
alternatives here so this is where we
started out that this is the two Knights
defense it's named after the two Black
Knights coming out and white came up we
played e5e takes and black did Knight
takes and that remember is not the
recommended move the recommended move is
Knight to a5 attacking the bishop all
right now white did Knight takes f7 and
white had great fun with a strong attack
it turns out that white could have had a
moderate advantage or a small advantage
without sacrificing any piece that's
another point sacrificing a piece to do
the fried liver attack is unnecessary
y can get it as an advantage with
another move
notice that the Queen is threatening
Queen takes Knight the other good move
is pawn the Queen for attacking the
center pawns and the Bishop protects the
knight at the same time blacks best move
is just to take the pawn
now let's move six white drives the
night back the night can't move because
we would wooden the knight on d5 Black
has a couple tricks up his sleeve to try
to hold on and to keep from losing a
piece he attacks the Bishop Bishop drops
back then he attacks the knight white is
attacking the knight black is attacking
White's Knight what's the right move for
white that is possible but there's a
better move you're going to lose your
knight so why not take something with
your night before you take his knight
pawns yeah
Knight takes f7 you're going to lose the
night anyway so the idea it's called a
desperado you're going to lose the
knight if you can take the knight and
make a threat you can win a pawn and you
can make the King come up so he can't
castle and without the pawn on f7 White
gets attacking lines on the white
diagonals so the best move is Knight
takes so they only move as King takes
and now we have time to take the knight
now black is behind in development so
his best move is to move his bishop out
checking white White's best move is to
block with the bishop now black doesn't
do Bishop takes Bishop check is that
would help white develop his knight by
Knight takes bishop and then the knight
to come up to e4 so black takes the
center pawn
and the white comes up Queen to f3 check
and the black king who retreats behind
the pawn but notice when the king goes
behind the pawn he blacks his rook in
the corner that gives white an advantage
white can castle and bring his rooks to
the middle and attack with both rooks
Black's gonna take a long time to get
his work out of the corner so white has
a positional advantage so white castles
now blacks position is kinda weak white
could take this pawn and once he takes
this pawn the bishop can go here and pin
the knight to the king and threaten
Bishop takes Knight
so this Knight needs to be protected in
the worst way so the best move is to and
bring the bishop to it protect but now
we hit the bishop with our rook there's
an opening principle if you can develop
a rook or some other piece and make a
threat you gain a temple to develop
another piece so we attacked the bishop
he has to retreat the bishop and then we
get to develop another piece so he
retreats
now we take his Bishop Knight takes now
he's on our Bishop we just let him take
our bishop no we don't I take that back
we need the bishop for attacking the
white squares and we gain a temple with
the bishop move attacking the rook the
rook moves what piece haven't we
developed yet for white the knight
so the knight comes out now let's
evaluate the position this is where
we're going to stop without sacrificing
a piece White has five pawns black has
an extra pawn but look at blacks pawn
they're all ragged and separated they're
all very weak and all the diagonals on
the white squares are weak blacks rook
is stuck in the corner by the king the
King can't move up to h7 to let the Rick
out because the bishop guards ch7 square
white even though he's a pawn down has a
big advantage and the computer says
White's advantage is 0.38 plus over
equals 0.38 that's almost point four
that's four tenths of a pawn two-fifths
of a pawn so it's almost at half a pawn
that's a good advantage it's not a
winning advantage black will be lucky to
survive so you can see that had white
white didn't have to do the sacrifice
going to the fried liver attack he could
have had a safe advantage by playing d4
alright now we're gonna go into the
fried liver attack and remember in our
game Knight takes King Queen here King
here Knight here the we did the retreat
well it turns out we said earlier that
the knight up was better let's take a
quick look at that all right so this is
better see the notation after this move
white has a slight advantage plus over
equals 0.63 6/10 of a pawn you divide 6
by 8 by 2 and 10 by 2 - you get 3/5 3/5
is more than half a pawn this is the
bigger this is a bigger advantage
actually then playing upon the Queen for
but it gets it goes for a long time we
got to go for a move 8 and I I did the
computer head the computer player moves
out to move 35 and white got it was able
to increase his advantage but I don't
know that all the moves were forced well
we run through them White's best move is
castles once again black protects the
knight with the c6 move we do the pawn
the Queen four attack but now the see
the night when it went to e7 block the
Queen so the Queen has a better
defensive move coming up trying to trade
Queens white can't afford to trade
Queens or he he loses the attack so he
retreats but he's still on the e5 pawn
now the King goes back to e7 he doesn't
go to d7 or d6 but we get a pawn now
where we got two pawns for the piece and
we're attacking the Queen Queen goes
over to the white square now we bring
our knight to the middle and see he gets
his Bishop out he didn't get his Bishop
out in the other variation cuz the King
was blocking the bishop remember so
blacks Queen and Bishop are in a much
better Square than in the other in the
in the game the other variation now we
don't have a great move with the knight
so we just defend it now black doesn't
take the knight because we do pawn takes
Knight driving blacks best Knight the
defending knight on d5 away and it would
open up the F file for the rook Black's
best move is to reorganize his Knights
he retreats that Knight attacking the
bishop we retreat here now he's going to
move his King away from the middle we
get the work to D 1 see how he hides the
King
behind the c6 pawn and he's there's no
check your cuz this pawns in the way
what does that suggest to you would be a
good move we can give that pawn up can't
we we just throw the pawn away because
we want to open up the diagonal for our
bishop he doesn't take the pawn because
we'd have Bishop to f4 check he plays
this Knight back and it takes away the
bishop to f4 check move however now we
can drive that night away from d5 with
the move c4 we're on the night and if
the knight moves we get Bishop to f4
check well black needs to get rid of
some of these attacking pieces now he
takes the knight we don't take the
bishop we take the knight black can get
his black squared Bishop out with check
we don't waste time moving the King we
need to develop our Bishop we give up on
the Bishop to f4 check we want to get
our Rick's together so we trade bishops
that helps blacks defense somewhat and
now black takes the pawn with Bishop
takes d5 threatening our each six pond
so we take the bishop Knight takes now
watch this
we're a whole piece down and it looks
like black has successfully defended his
position but White has the rook
sacrifice Queen up check see how the
pawn on e6 works with the Queen he can't
go to b8 it would be Queen to d6 check
King the see a trick to see one would be
checkmate yeah
to go to d8 now the King and pawn are
lined up and we bring our rook over and
we get rook takes pawn check he moves
the King over we take the pawn with the
Queen threatening Queen down check we're
here he went here okay we take with the
rook where does the King go he goes here
then we pin him and it turns out we win
this because we're going to win one of
the two either the g7 pond or the b7
pawn and we're going to have an extra
pawn on each side of the board maybe we
can move our king safe we can move our H
pawn up a couple pawns and the King can
hide on h2 and the Queen can nurse the
pawns up and the rooks aren't going to
be able to hold it off now the rooks can
hold off the Queen if the pawns are even
and the rooks protect each other and
they protect the pawns and it's the draw
not a draw in this case okay so he had
to move the King out of the way and now
we do Queen takes threatening Queen down
he comes up here Queen down King to f8
watch this he seven he can't go up
because we have pawn up double-check
that would lead to checkmate King over
now while we have Queen here only move
is to block Queen here check only move
is to block watch this
we have a perpetual check if we wanted a
draw by perpetual check we try to win
Queen here threatening rook to d8 he
worked to c8 we do work to da Tenny way
he has to take our queen we take his
queen we get his other rook see that he
and we win the H pawned were a pawn up
and we have winning chances in the
endings 1.01 advantage approximately a
pawn now I couldn't win this ending but
grandmasters have winning chances if
they play it just right so I stopped the
analysis here so that so even if black
played better white does have some
winning chances that's why black should
never let white play the fried liver
attack though remember that don't play
into the fried liver debt but if your if
you want to have fun and speech s it
would be great fun to try these things
out I doubt very much I most chess
players would have no idea of all these
maneuvers that the computer came up with
so anyway that should wrap it up thanks
for coming tonight
[Music]